hello guys Gregory Alba here I'm going
to be doing a trailer reaction and
review of the film passengers sorry and
Jennifer Lawrence and Chris Pratt but
before I do that I wanted to give a
special announcement I'm going to be
going to Switzerland
I was just confirmed a few days ago I
mean it's been talks for a while but the
Zurich Film Festival is going to be
going on and I got invited to go over
there so they're flying me out they're
putting me up in a hotel going to the
press badges so I can go through all the
interviews and stuff really grateful to
be going cause I'm a huge movie fanatic
this is an event where a lot of huge
[ __ ] people in the industry go I'm
talking like the people that tend to go
to the Oscars and the Sun dancing Cannes
like they all tend to go there too so
this festive looks like an awesome it's
just as big as stuff like Sundance or
Cannes like the biggest celebs go
they're the most respected directors go
there too I'm talking like current
popular people go there as well I'm so
excited to be going I leave in just a
few hours but I just wanted to put this
video up I've been looking forward to
the trailer for passengers for a while
it stars Jennifer Lawrence stars Chris
Pratt it's from the director of the
guide to the imitation game it's written
by the guy who one of the co writers of
the new Doctor Strange movie prometheus
I I know he's co-writing the mummy movie
and also the new van Helsing movie and I
think he's also one of the co writers of
the new Pacific Rim film this plot
sounds really cool it was blacklisted
for a while so it was like one of those
really popular scripts that just was
never getting made it was originally on
a reason Reese Witherspoon I believe but
now they got two bigger stars for this
with a bigger budget I have enough
talking Greg let's watch this already
cool
hello
he asked me on a date
nice she didn't seem that impressed yeah
you clean up pretty good yourself
did she look fine missing no no I very
nice
took you long enough to ask so why did
you give up your life on her we boarded
the abalone with the destination 120
years hibernation means we'll wake up in
a new century a new plant
but a year ago everything changed
oh you know what's going on nobody else
is awake I think something went wrong
with the hibernation box
we woke up too soon
years too soon oh you should go back to
sleep
yeah
know something big
we do
do you trust me
Wow
this ship's gonna go
I don't want to go to space man
there's something I have to tell you
Andi Garcia hurts fish bird I know these
guys are ready this breezy we woke up
early ah oh I am intrigued that looks so
cool I heard most of this film was
primarily shot just pretty much around
the two leads you know Jennifer Lawrence
and Chris Pratt the director in an
interview he was talking about how he
wanted to make sure that yeah there's
gonna be the spectacle there's gonna be
the cool sci-fi massive epicness behind
it but he said he really wanted to make
sure this was character driven and I
really like that in this trailer I
really feel like I'm getting that in
this trailer because yeah actually like
the last 30 40 seconds of this trailer
was you know the intensity the plot
unfolding the mystery surrounding it
because I was already intrigued by the
idea of something went wrong and these
two people woke up very early 90 years
too early but capping that off at the
end with Chris Pratt going there's a
reason we woke up early that got me
really hooked I want now I just really
want to know what the [ __ ] going on
Chris Pratt and Jennifer Lawrence they
look like they're gonna do a fantastic
job Jennifer Lawrence is one of the most
consistently strong actresses out there
even though I don't know it's my like
ego criticism that comes up sometimes
where I hear her talking or the
narration and I'm just like oh my god
Jennifer Lawrence narrating again
knowing how who's that tends to go for
me when I watch a film with her in it I
tend to go yeah she does a fantastic job
Chris Pratt so cool to see how far he's
come since parks and recreation
he is now with such a sexy Hollywood
lead I'm really excited for this because
this is one of those big-budget
Hollywood sci-fi epics yet it does seem
like that they gave Chris Pratt and
Jennifer Lawrence really cool characters
here I like the plot already of having
to travel to this other you know
colonial planet because there's a lot of
people asleep in there but they can't
just wake everyone up it's just these
two so they're kind of like secluded in
space with you know their michael sheen
robot and i want to see a michael gene
does because it was kind of funny when
like he was like freaking out and
sliding across the
our table and everything I don't get
where there's a bar there I thought
everyone was supposed to be asleep it
sounds like they were preparing for
people to have a good time maybe that's
part of the plot Laurence Fishburne you
know ever since films like The Matrix
love seeing him a sci-fi Andy Garcia
real hit or miss when it comes to me
enjoying his role Jennifer Lawrence and
Chris Pratt they seem like real people
in this film they seem very relatable
they seem like human beings I could come
across one day so seeing like them in
like the space danger situations like oh
my god man I just can't imagine going to
space I'm flying on a plane and I'm
freaking out about that the whole idea
of space travel just freaks me out and
the cinematography yeah that looks great
the effects look really well-done we're
seeing the shots of space the spacecraft
all the production design looks
fantastic it looks really looks really
solid but the thing is that this looks
like an emotional sci-fi adventure as
well with romance and actually I think
Jennifer Lawrence talked about how she
had to have a sex scene with Chris Pratt
and that she said she was very
uncomfortable we might finally see
Jennifer Lawrence's breasticles in a
scene in a movie thank you Chris Pratt's
but coming our way - yeah star-lord and
mystique I should have thought of a joke
about that before filming some people
this looks like the kind of show that
some people might comment being like
they showed us the whole movie I don't
think so I honestly can't tell you
here's everything that goes on in this
film and here's what's really happening
this trailer really hooked me I thought
it did a great job on its marketing and
I'm definitely gonna be there to watch
it I love a good sci-fi film sci-fi to
me is some of the best form of you know
movie entertainment in general because
that's where it's science fiction so you
really get the chance for a writer and
director everyone to just come together
and really work their imagination and
it's great seeing great talent like
Chris Pratt and Jennifer Lawrence really
committing their all to it I imagine as
an actor that it's harder to get very
emotional and be really into it in
something that's so fictitious as
opposed to something that's more real
and that's what makes for a great
performance for me when you see
something like that so hell yeah
passengers you can see me
the passenger's seat next seat not
trying that alright guys subscribe to
the real rejects if you're in
Switzerland keep a lookout for me and
follow me on my social networks not sure
how the upload schedule will be
depending on how busy my days will be
out there I'm gonna be out there for
about a week so I don't know what the
elbows will be like but when I get back
for sure we'll be consistent again thank
you for tuning in
goodbye